what are your thoughts sticking on
artificial intelligence a little bit
about the displacement of jobs that's
another perspective that candidates like
Andrew yang talked about being getting
forever yang Yang so he unfortunately
speaking of yang Yang has recently
dropped out I know it was very
disappointing and depressing yeah but
the on the positive side he's I think
launching a podcast so really cool yeah
that's he just announced that I'm sure
he'll try to talk you into trying to
come on to the podcast so about
ratatouille yeah maybe he'll be more
welcoming of the ratatouille argument
what are your thoughts on his concerns
of the displacement of jobs of
automations out of the of course there's
positive impacts that could come from
automation they I and but there could
also be negative impacts and within that
framework what are your thoughts about
universal basic income so these
interesting new ideas of how we can
empower people in the economy i I think
he was a hundred percent right on almost
every dimension we see this in in
squares business I mean he identified
truck drivers I'm from Missouri and he
certainly pointed to the concern and the
issue that people from where I'm from
feel every single day that is often
invisible and not talked about enough
you know the next big one is cashiers
this is where it pertains to squares
business we are seeing more and more of
the point-of-sale moved to the
individual customers hand in the form of
their phone and apps and pre-order and
order ahead we're seeing more kiosks
we're seeing more things like Amazon go
and the number of workers in as a
cashier and Rito's immense and you know
there's there's no real answers on how
they transform their skills and and work
and into something else and I think that
does lead to a lot of
really negative ramifications and the
important point that he brought up
around universal basic income is given
that this shift is going to come and
given it's going to take time to set
people up with new skills and new
careers they need to have a floor to be
able to survive and this thousand
dollars a month is such a floor it's not
going to incentivize you to quit your
job because it's not enough but it will
enable you to not have to worry as much
about just getting on day to day so that
you can focus on what I'm what am I
going to do now and what am I going to
what skills do I need to acquire and I
think I think that you know a lot of
people point to the fact that you know
during the industrial age we we had the
same concerns around automation factory
lines and everything worked out ok but
the the biggest change is just the
velocity and the centralization of a lot
of the things that make this work which
is the data and the algorithms that work
on this on this data I think the the
second biggest scary thing is just how
around AI is just who actually owns the
data and who can operate on it and are
we able to share the insights from the
data so that we can also build
algorithms that help our needs or help
our business or what not so that's where
I think regulation could play a strong
and positive part first looking at the
primitives of AI and the tools we use to
build these services that will
ultimately touch every single aspect of
the human experience and then how data
where data is owned and how its how its
shared
so those those are the answers that as a
society as a world we need to have
better answers around which we're
currently not they're just way too
centralized into a few very very large
companies but I think is about on with
identifying the problem and proposing
solutions that would actually work
at least that we'd learn from that you
could expand or evolve but I mean it's I
think it's ubi is well well past its
it's do I mean it was certainly
trumpeted by Martin Luther King and and
even even before him as well and like
you said like the you know the exact
thousand dollar mark might be might not
be the correct one but you should take
the stuff to try to implement these
solutions and see see what works
you